ce soir il en reste plus que 21 21
candidats coachée par l'équipe de la
voix en scène pour assurer la meilleure
prestation possible et se faire plaisir
pour me donner encore des nouvelles de
nouveaux objectifs en fait donc je me
suis dit pourquoi pas en fait tout
simplement
le but c'est de donner une chance à des
gens qui qui qui tâtonne qui savent pas
forcément s'y sont faits pour ça s'ils
ont envie de faire ça jusqu'au bout
leurs vignes pas et on les met face à
des professionnels
en plus des trois catégories jugés par
des professionnels le public avait aussi
sa voix a donné pour désigner son
chouchou de la soirée le concert était
diffusé sur internet message des votes
ont pu dépasser les frontières de magny
les hameaux
la preuve que ça marche en direct de
même dans tous les styles représentés
ainsi que tous les âges
[Musique]
à 9 ans et 2000 sanaa est la plus jeune
de la compétition pour l'encourager son
équipe de foot lui a fait la surprise de
lui envoyer un message
[Musique]
cinq heures de show qui ont récompensé
quatre artistes dont le rappeur et nîmes
d'un coeur tu as dans la catégorie
auteur compositeur interprète nos droits
et nos devoirs
on nous dit que l'homme est libre de ses
choix sauf qu on oublie de préciser que
c'est l'argent est roi